these days it feels like every sci-fi
film ever made has been followed up by
another for some reason or another
though there are some sci-fi movies that
either never got a sequel or ended up
stopping a whole franchise in its tracks
here are a few of those movies in etv
extraterrestrial a lonely suburban boy
named elliot discovers a friendly alien
in the woods
with whom he soon forms an indelible
psychokinetic bond
it became the highest grossing movie of
its time received nine academy award
nominations and solidified director
steven spielberg as the premier
filmmaker of his generation
in fact pretty much the whole world fell
in love with the little alien man with a
glowing heart
meaning spielberg and screenwriter
melissa matheson had to at least
entertain the notion of an e.t sequel
together they wrote a nine-page outline
for et2 nocturnal fears a movie very
unlike the original et
and that it was a sci-fi horror movie
that barely featured e.t at all
the plot revolved around some other
aliens who received et's distress call
from the first movie
elliot and gertie quickly tracked them
down thinking e.t is returned
but these aliens are actually
gremlin-like monsters with red eyes and
sharp teeth who end up torturing the
kids
using his bond with e.t elliott calls
for help and his alien pal shows up just
in time to save them
apparently spielberg quickly realized
that this was all a really
really bad idea as you once said at an
american film institute event
sequels can be very dangerous because
they compromise your truth as an artist
i think a sequel to et would do nothing
but rob the original of its virginity
first published in 1982 battlefield
earth is an incredibly long and complex
sci-fi epic by scientology founder l ron
hubbard
set in the year 3000 it tells the story
of earth's 1000 year occupation by
monstrous humanoid aliens called cyclos
it reduced humanity to a population of
around thirty thousand
that is until noble hero johnny good boy
tyler sparks a revolution and gains
himself an enemy in turtle
the wicked chief of cyclo security john
travolta tried to get a film adaptation
of battlefield earth going for more than
15 years
only finally amassing the hollywood
capital needed to make it happen in the
late 1990s
unfortunately this was too long for
travolta to play the role of tyler as he
hoped and he was instead cast as turl
he was also a producer on the project
and had intended to tell the battlefield
story over the course of two films
despite some fancy special effects in
travolta's star power however
battlefield earth crashed made with a
budget of 73 million dollars it took an
earth-wide total of 29 million dollars
and the few who did see the movie hated
it
it's got a 3 score on rotten tomatoes
and it won in every category in which it
was nominated at the razzies
as a result the sequel simply never got
off the ground
opening over the 4th of july weekend in
1996 the original independence day
packed in all the elements of a perfect
popcorn movie
special effects an all-star cast and a
crowd-pleasing plot
in which humans pulled together to expel
and eliminate an extraterrestrial menace
the film earned a then record of 104.3
million dollars in its opening week and
took in a total of 306 million dollars
in north america alone
a sequel then was inevitable but it
still took 20 years to get going
independence day resurgence hit theaters
in the summer of 2016 and eked out an
american grand total of 103 million
dollars
less than what the original film had
pulled in during its first week and
that's before you adjust for inflation
there are several reasons why resurgence
underperformed it's likely that will
smith passing on the sequel turned off
audiences
and the 20-year wait between the films
can't have helped either regardless
before the release of resurgence
director roland emerick discussed his
plans for a third independence day movie
one that would take jeff goldblum's
character into space to lead an attack
on hostile aliens
take the fight to them when do we leave
we're gonna kick some serious alien ass
but the lackluster numbers for
resurgence seem to have killed any
possibility of that happening
resurgence producer dean devlin told lmr
online in 2018
currently i personally have no plans on
doing another one
disney already controlled a number of
major movie brands and franchises when
it finalized its acquisition of 21st
century fox in march 2019.
that said the box buyout was still a
huge deal in the industry
included in the 71 billion dollar price
tag were the film rights to the x-men
30 percent of hulu ownership of the
simpsons and the difficult decision on
what to do with nearly 300 films that
had been in development at fox
one of those films was the sequel to
chronicle the innovative found footage
sci-fi about three teenagers who find
themselves wielding incredible
telekinetic abilities
the 2012 original earned 126 million
dollars at the worldwide box office but
when disney acquired the property they
clearly didn't think the franchise had
much of a future
still seven years had passed between the
release of chronicle and the disney
acquisition
why didn't fox make a sequel in the
interim well it probably has a lot to do
with the creative minds behind the first
film for one
screenwriter max landis was accused of
sexual assault in 2017
and since then his career is pretty much
disintegrated meanwhile director josh
trank admitted to collider that he
intentionally made things hard when fox
asked about a sequel
he said i made it difficult for them to
set up meetings i was dodgy about stuff
because i really didn't ever want to see
chronicle 2 happen that was my worst
nightmare
once upon a time disney thought that the
whole world was ready for a sci-fi epic
based on a forgotten century-old book
andrew stanton of pixar convinced disney
to buy the rights to edgar riceborough's
1912 novel a princess of mars and then
let him direct the adaptation
even though he'd never made a live
action movie disney sunk 263.7 million
dollars on the production of john carter
plus another 100 million dollars on
marketing
making it one of the most expensive
movies ever made that's a lot of cash to
invest in a film based on an obscure
property and starring a cast of relative
unknowns to boot
released in march 2012 critical reviews
for john carter were middling at best
and they did nothing to entice audiences
to what was already a hard sell
after a moderately robust 30 million
dollar opening weekend
the film sank fast and wound up bringing
in just 73 million dollars in the us
it didn't do much better overseas either
with a final global take of
million dollars disney's massive
financial losses made john carter into
one of the biggest bombs of all time
thus putting the brakes on the
development of any of the 10 additional
books in burrows bar some saga
in 2014 the rights to the series
reverted back to the author's estate
putting any last chance of a john carter
sequel firmly in the ground
based on a cancelled 1960s tv series
that ran for only three years star trek
the motion picture hit the big screen in
1979
a testament to the property's devoted
and enduring fan base
through the 80s and 90s star trek became
one of the most successful and long
lasting film franchises of all time
then in 1994 the cast of the original
six movies passed the torch to a new
generation of heroes with the aptly
named 1994 film star trek generations
the first three films in the rebooted
series performed well at the box office
bringing in an average return of 129
million dollars
interest dropped off precipitously
however with the release of star trek
nemesis in december 2002
the fourth next generation movie took in
67 million dollars at the us box office
a respectable number but not all that
great in comparison to its predecessors
as such the movie killed star trek at
the multiplex for the time being
with part of the blame falling to
competition from several other
franchises
at the time of its release nemesis faced
competition from the lord of the rings
the two towers harry potter and the
chamber of secrets and the santa claus
ii as a result the star trek franchise
faded into the ether and didn't make a
resurgence until j.j abrams rebooted the
series seven years later
hellboy was a major hit character for
indie comic publisher darkhorse
the character is a red-skinned
super-powered half-demon who works for
the bureau for paranormal research and
defense and in doing so protects earth
from creatures and forces of pure evil
fantasy icon guillermo del toro wrote
and directed 2004's hellboy and hellboy
2 the golden army but he wasn't hired
for a third film star
ron perlman didn't want to make the
movie without del toro either so
producers opted to reboot the series
instead
bringing on a new creative team and
replacing pearlman with david harbour
the likable breakout star of the netflix
mega hit stranger things
critics don't often praise sci-fi
monster movies but they love del toro's
two hellboy movies which earned rotten
tomato scores of 81 percent and 86
respectively audiences also enjoyed the
first hellboys to the tune of a combined
260.2 million dollars at the box office
the 2019 hellboy however failed to
capture the hearts of either critics or
film goers reviewers savaged the movie
which brought in just 44.6 million
dollars at the worldwide box office in
its first theatrical run
this attempt at a fresh rebooted
franchise simply crashed and burned
sending any possibility of a sequel
straight to hell
it really does feel like the terminator
franchise is impossible to kill
i'll be back it all started with 1984
sci-fi and warflick the terminator
starring arnold schwarzenegger as a
cyborg sent back in time to kill sarah
connor and her unborn son john who will
one day lead the human resistance
against the machines
terminator 2 judgment day found
schwarzenegger playing a different time
hopping terminator entrusted with
protecting teenage john connor from
another deadlier terminator
and so it went with more terminator
installments digging up more and more
holes in the mind-boggling timeline
all leading up to 2019's terminator dark
fate
despite the brand recognition and
despite being the first terminator in
decades to feature both schwarzenegger
and hamilton
dark fate was a flop it was the first in
the series since the 1984 original not
to clear
350 million dollars at the box office
grossing just 261 million dollars
worldwide
a number even more disappointing
considering it cost 185 million dollars
to produce
although you should never say never with
a franchise this big those measly
returns could mean that the terminator
franchise has finally met its fate
a hollywood icon mel brooks's best films
tended to parody entire genres of movies
westerns with blazing saddles for
example are a classic horror with young
frankenstein
naturally then in the 1980s he turned
his hand to star wars
spaceballs lovingly sent up the george
lucas saga but also pointed out just how
silly it all was
with rick moranis as the unsure darth
vader-esque dark helmet
bill pullman as the on-the-nose han solo
parody lone star
and john candy as the chewbacca-like
barf brooks himself even shows up for an
extended cameo as yogurt
an old and wise yoda ripoff who's
literally just there to sell merch
space falls the coloring book space
falls to lunchbox
space balls the breakfast cereal spanx
falls the flamethrower
naturally considering the franchise it's
spoofing spaceballs also promises a
sequel in spaceballs 2 the search for
more money
sadly this will probably never happen
since many members of the original cast
have passed away
since the first film's 1987 release most
importantly of all however moranis has
almost
entirely retired from acting and as the
94 year old brooks once told parade
magazine
without rick i wouldn't do it and though
moranis has recently returned to the
screen for a few select projects that's
most likely the end of that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]